mobile homes perfected by humans but
invented by snails there are many
misconceptions about mobile or
manufactured homes for instance right
now you may be picturing something that
looks like this but for decades the
industry has been trying to change that
image running ads like this one you
bought a mobile home
today's manufactured home factory build
quality at a price that makes sense we
have three big bedrooms
[Music]
today's manufactured home you bottomed
out okay
I think I'll get it but for the record
that sexy saxophone riff would make a
reveal of anything seem good here I'll
show you
you bought a taxidermy fox
[Music]
[Applause]
box but but it is it is true in history
it can be genuinely hard to tell the
difference between manufactured homes
and conventional homes just like it's
hard to tell the difference between
Jessica Chastain and Bryce Dallas Howard
the difference is like a mobile home
Bryce Dallas Howard is assembled
off-site than placed on wheels and moved
to her permanent location around 20
million people live in mobile homes
that's roughly one in eighteen Americans
and they're one of America's last
affordable housing options costing up to
50% less per square foot than a
conventional house which is great but in
recent years some of the biggest
investors in America have moved into
this industry according to one new
report over a hundred thousand home
sites traditionally run by mom-and-pop
businesses are now owned or partly owned
by private equity firms like these so
the homes of some of the poorest people
in America are getting snapped up by
some of the richest people in America
and luckily there'll be no problems
whatsoever except I'm obviously kidding
it's going terribly if you do want to
hear me lie about stories to make you
feel better you might enjoy our spin-off
show everything's fine with John Oliver
did you know Isis is just hamsters this
little terrorist name is dumpling and he
doesn't even know how to use his gun
sadly back in the real world the truth
is the rise of big-money investors in
mobile homes has led to a corresponding
spike in rents fees and local news
stories like these people living at a
local mobile home park outraged over the
sharp increase in lot rent rents were
raised by as much as 36% rents were
raised by nearly 60% Ella Carter lives
on a fixed income her lot rents just
gone up and it all adds up to a bill she
can't afford now it's a matter of okay
now which medication am I going to take
and half so that I can make a stretch
out a little bit longer that's clearly
horrible because nobody should be made
to stretch out medicine it's sad enough
when you stretch out your almost empty
bottle of shampoo by adding a bunch of
water and if you didn't relate to that
joke you haven't suffered a single day
in your life
so tonight tonight let's take a look at
the mobile home industry let's start
with the company that sells more mobile
homes than any other Clayton Homes
controlled by one of the richest men in
America Warren Buffett's although the
company's ads choose to feature a more
down-home spokesman what do I know about
Clayton Homes I know they're built right
here in America and they know the
difference between a house and a home
hey miss Kay a home is where you get
your famous sweet potato powder honey
and y'all know how we all try to make
miss Kay happy happy happy
clean homes good call judging by that
creepy delivery there's just no way that
getting her famous sweet potato pie is
not also code for some kind of
disgusting sex act it probably means
miss case smearing pie filling on his
ball sack while a live duck scraped it
off with his bill and if it does good
call but but the key difference between
a mobile and a conventional home has
nothing to do with pie it has to do with
how it retains its value just listen to
finance guru Dave Ramsey give his
no-nonsense take on whether or not you
should buy one mobile homes go down in
value it's the only thing you own that
you live in that goes down in value even
if you buy dirt under it that goes up
and value more than it goes down in
value so it appears you didn't lose
money you lost money you buy a $50,000
mobile home in a few years it's a
$10,000 mobile home I mean cars go down
and buy you mobile homes go down in
value it's a car you sleep in I'm gonna
say I find the negativity of his tongue
genuinely refreshing there that guy
should replace Jim Cramer on his show
no more running around excitedly
pressing buttons like a little boy at an
arcade just an angry old grump hunched
over a desk telling you you're going to
lose money so so mobile homes may be a
terrible investment for people buying
them but they've been an incredible
investment for Warren Buffett's Clayton
Homes generated pre-tax earnings of nine
hundred and eleven million dollars last
year and they've done that not just by
selling homes but by financing them as
well because instead of being financed
with mortgages mobile homes tend to be
bought with high interest short
chattel loans the kanji used to buy a
car or a TV and an investigation a few
years back found Clayton relies on
predatory sales practices exorbitant
fees and interest rates that can exceed
15% trapping many buyers in loans they
can't afford now Clayton strenuously
denies all of that saying the report was
based on isolated incidents and that its
customers reports high levels of
satisfaction although I will point out
that one of those isolated incidents was
this call a Clayton customer got when
she fell behind on payments
what do you suggest except for the
things that you already suggest which
doesn't work holy-shit
go donate blood I guess one way to get
your customers to report high levels of
satisfaction is to make sure they're all
feeling lightheaded after you literally
bleed them dry but but one of
the biggest problems here isn't even to
do with how you pay for a mobile home or
how quickly it loses its value it's
where you put it because around a third
of mobile home dwellers owned their
homes but don't own the land underneath
it that's because they live in mobile
home parks and pay rent on that land to
the park owner but in recent years large
investors have been snatching those
parks up and either tearing them down or
ratcheting up rent and fees as these
women experienced firsthand the end-all
family decided to sell the park and they
sold it to the Carlyle Group
first of all Carlyle started off with an
immediate 8% increase space rent so that
was a threat to most of us who are
living on fixed income I don't know
what's gonna happen I may be forced to
leave everything like doctors my friends
the life I've known here even though I
own my own it's true that woman may lose
her home so the Carlyle Group an
investment firm with 216 billion dollars
in assets can make more money for their
shareholders if the concept of income
in equality came to life that is the
sentence it would scream when it orgasms
now Carlisle Carlisle insists that the
price heights were to pay for park
improvements which makes complete sense
if you ask these why they got
into private equity I'm sure they say to
you Oh
to break-even on investments in the
beautification of affordable housing why
else would we do this
I also apparently have to tell you that
Carlisle has a safety net program for
low-income residents although you should
know it only applies to 21 of the 800
Lots in that park so it's a safety net
that only catches 3% of people just like
the one they use at my favorite circus a
pile of dead trapeze artists it's fun
for the whole family unless you're a
family of one of those trapeze artists
and if you think it well look that's
terrible but if those women live in
mobile homes why don't they just move
well there is a problem with that as one
of those women will tell you although
they call them mobile homes it would
cost twenty thousand to move this home
out here plus it went once you move them
in and they settle moving a mouth
couldn't help destroy them she's right
it can cost thousands of dollars to move
mobile homes if you can move them at all
that is why 80% of mobile homes never
move so mobile homes are mobile about as
much as a king crab is an actual king
it's just not except in some parts of
Alaska where it wills the power of a
despot but even then it constitutionally
shares power with moose Parliament so so
King is really a more ceremonial title
there Alaska's a fascinating place and
this this lack of mobility for tenants
is actually part of the attraction for
big investors and to see just how
cynical and predatory the industry can
be meet Frank Rolfe his company is one
of the largest park operators in the
u.s. controlling over 30,000 home sites
in 25 states Roth is an evangelist for
the wonders of mobile home park
investing just look at this
uplifting message that he made ahead of
the 2012 election about what it would
mean for his industry taped for some
reason in front of a shitty green-screen
Oval Office if Mitt Romney wins things
are good but if Barrack Obama wins
things are good
you see it doesn't much matter who wins
the election all that matters is that
the statistics show that Americans will
continue to get poorer in that lower
half of the population Wow what
president wet webcam is essentially
saying there is no matter what happens
the poor will suffer and we will feast
on their rich marrow and as you can see
it's casual Friday here at the White
House which is why I sit before you
looking like a divorced dad at a
parent-teacher conference Roth is
completely shameless about the degree to
which his business depends on having a
captive customer base positively
comparing it to running a Waffle House
where everyone is chained to the booths
a concept so deeply chilling I think it
may have just inspired jaws and peels
next movie now now you should know Ralph
maintains that that line was taken out
of context in fact he has a whole page
on his website about it claiming he was
just talking about the incredibly
consistent revenues in mobile home parks
so he wasn't suggesting that he's a
heartless person whose customers are
stuck there with him holding all the
cards deciding for himself how high he
wants their rent to go to see him say
that you'd need to enroll in his online
mobile home university which we did and
found seminars like this but I found it
again just as a heartless person is that
you know the customers are stuck there
they don't have any option they can't
afford to move the trailer they don't
have three grand so they're the only way
they can they can object to your Rhett
raises to walk off and leave the trailer
in which case it becomes abandoned
property and you recycle if another
person in it so you really hold all the
cards so the question is what do you
want to do how high do you want to go
Wow
usually when someone is that
contemptuous of poor people there
immediately visited by the ghost of
Christmas future
now now maybe maybe Roth will claim that
that quote is out of context - and that
he's not arguing that they're hostages
to hear him say that you need to send
away for Roth's
audio seminar on running mobile home
parks which we also did and found
thick's were the big drivers to making
money is is the ability increased the
RET we didn't have them hostage if they
weren't stuck in those homes and though
in the
mobile home labs it'd be a whole
different picture Frank rolls mobile
home university is basically a crash
course in how to be an although
having taken that course I'd argue that
if that's what you're looking for save
your money and just follow Piers Morgan
on Twitter for one afternoon
isn't just online if you attend his
mobile home bootcamp he'll even take you
on a field trip to love a park when you
get to the park you'll be shocked and
turned off by for example the beach
towel in the window instead of an actual
curtain that doesn't mean anything well
you got to worry about are the following
items infrastructure density expense age
of home and location got it they're
teaching people about mobile home parks
oh yeah that's good no it isn't done
it's really not good telling that woman
that people are just there to learn
about mobile home parks is like telling
a lobster people came to the restaurant
to learn about crustacean habitats
that's good are those knives and forks
to help remove these tiny rubber bands
from her claws no they're going to eat
you
so with that woman and many mobile home
residents like her in danger of having
their lives turned upside down it is
worth asking is there anything that can
be done here well one potential solution
is for residents to band together and
buy their own Park keeping it out of the
hands of speculators or developers and
while that sounds inherently like a long
shot there are nonprofit groups that
have had real success in helping tenants
get financing to do just that
what would help is to have laws in every
state that give residents the right of
first refusal and time to raise funds if
the current owner plans to sell but
until laws like that are put in place
which they absolutely should be there
are some key things to bear in mind if
you want to rent a mobile home that's
fine if you can afford to buy one and
put it on land that you own that's fine
but buying a mobile home and renting the
land underneath it can be financially
catastrophic and it is very important
that anyone considering doing that knows
the risks involved and I'll tell you
what would have been helpful all along
if the marketing for these homes had
always made those risks completely clear
you bought a mobile home
today's manufactured home I can't
believe you bought a house I really did
it it's exactly like a house and what a
beautiful piece of land I don't own the
land though and that's actually a super
important difference look at you all
grown up with the mortgage it's a chat
alone with an astronomical interest rate
the important thing is it's an
investment in your future it'll actually
only ever go down in value and since the
private equity firm bought the park my
rent has skyrocketed are you listening
to me oh I love these decorative bottles
oh that's my blood I have to sell my
blood and plasma in order to make loan
payments
[Applause]
but home is where the sweet potato pie
is I didn't make that did you make that
is that burning your hands are you a
witch I want to see your garden no no no
no don't don't look out there here I go
do it oh there she is look she can't
afford to move you hold all the cards
he's right it's like a Waffle House
where I am chained to my booth that's
house delicious what is wrong with you
speaking of delicious
you
[Applause]